we are seeing more signs that Las Vegas
is coming back to life as covet 19
restrictions continue to ease across our
state more hotels and casinos have
reopened their doors today including the
link on the Las Vegas Strip that's where
we find Sasha Loftus she's joining us
live to break down what we can expect
right through the weekend Sasha
Brian good evening we're actually right
behind the Lincoln if you look behind me
you can see there's a lot of traffic
driving by that wasn't actually the case
a few weeks ago it was kind of a ghost
town in this entire area but so many say
it's now nice to see things appear more
normal again now as you mentioned the
link opened its doors at 11:00 this
morning
it follows other popular resorts like
Caesars Palace Harrah's the Bellagio the
Flamingo and MGM Grand the Nevada Gaming
Control Board says many properties are
going with phase three openings based on
demand we spoke to a few people visiting
Las Vegas from other states today they
say they're happy to be back it's really
nice that everything's back open up in
there
getting back to the usual you know
really nice that were able to like start
having fun again it's how I breathe
inside all the time
now we checked a few sites online to see
how much rooms are going for right now
they vary from 50 bucks a night to about
200 depending on the property you can
even find a few for less than $50 if you
look hard enough on the strip now the
next resorts to open look to be Paris
and the west skate those are set to
reopen on June 18th now obviously with
strips our strip properties reopening
everyday and things changing it is kind
of hard to keep up so we have everything
you need to know on our website 8 News
now.com for now reporting live Sascha
Loftus 8 News now
all right thanks very much sauce